all right so this is James I was really
hoping it's gonna be James Baxter again
I was so hoping but we got so injustice
good I was so happy that we got this
character by the way I just want to
state this really quickly before we go
any further this is just like the one
episode where he laughed I think like
once and that was it like yeah it was
amazingly quiet yeah you just came in
it's just like you know wow you're like
really really quiet in this one I'm like
okay let's get the episode here so
they're going around people's Finn Jake
and a character named James who I don't
know what he was was he like ice cream
sandwich or something like that
something like that or maybe one of
those wafers you know like those little
wafers have a little cream in whatever I
never know what they're called but like
but always only good no not vanilla
wafers but no I know what you're talking
one those are good yeah I can't run what
they're called but anyway it's some
piece of candy named James is piloting
this ship or helping pilot this ship
there's going over this area that looks
like desert and I guess she was looking
to what what you looking to do but they
can just sort of like bring people there
or something I was like goals like
terraform if I remember right yeah
something like that
and sure enough all these jelly donut
zombies come back like the ones that
chased uh Simon and Marcy and and she
seemed to know what they were - should
tell they you know that creature from a
long time ago aside she freaked oh yeah
so she knows what they are and yeah so
they're trying to get inside this ship
and they're all pretty annoyed with
James because he's intentionally an
annoying character and when uh and all
these things seem to keep going wrong
like the the circuits are calm the
flares are being shot off and stuff that
they're just say you know what the hell
James because they keep thinking he's
doing it because he's just so kind of
dim-witted and annoying and such and
just slowing everything down so finally
they figure there's only one way to get
out
that's one whoever is the biggest has to
be eaten so that they can get out Finn
volunteers but then people's knock them
out knocks Jake out pretty much
convinces James to go and do it and
that's exactly what happens and he gets
pretty much eaten alive and Peebles runs
them all out and says Finn you could
have done it because I can clone James
he's candy I can do that I can't clone
you and they have both a funeral and a
welcoming back up James Finn says I have
no idea this is a good thing or a bad
thing and turns also that she was one to
sabotage to all the plants because she
knew none of them would work and that
her calculation said this is the only
one that would work and that's what they
had to do so they're they don't know how
to feel and then we see James zombie
James climb out to pee and a whole bunch
of zombies go with him um yikes I don't
know um like well first of all I really
did not laugh that much in I mean I'm
really trying to think alike I think I
laughed at is this a good thing or a bad
thing
you know cuz that's kind of what you're
thinking throughout this ending do I
mean the whole thing um I loved the
opening I loved thing coming in with a
suit bandages eyes head going up to Jake
who's just sobbing over something that
happened and he's in a suit - it's
probably a funeral and everything and
then you know people's is there from all
the people saying you know I'm so glad
you've all come here today and then it
cuts to showing what happens like that's
a great leave in because you're like
what is going on um well I did like that
wouldn't finish like oh it's okay you
know put on a normal face he's like kind
of like this and I love how his face
doesn't change at all and he's like and
it take is like it's like don't worry
everything is like you're okay I'm okay
just give me a few months yeah so
I don't know okay the first thing that
always pops in my head is that and this
is part of the problem with the fact
that J can turn into anything is he can
turn into anything you could get
everybody out of that so easily and
stuff and that this is a situation where
that really does bother me especially
when people's does like all the
calculations and stuff that's like
bullcrap you have a guy can change
anything but sorry I wake up said you
got it it's just okay it's a little bit
sad nitpicker walk because there's a ton
of times where it's like Jake could have
saved the day and they don't address it
or use it but that's just sort of the
whatever the limitations or liberties of
the show I guess if they made it where
he's worn out or he's been injured or ya
know I you know I never actually thought
about it but now that you say it it's
like yeah it's actually a really good
point I mean he could have easily just
gotten out of there yeah I really don't
get the idea of people sabotaging
everything because she calculated that
won't work why doesn't she just explain
why or say the calculations why well the
time it takes referring to sabotage the
plan she could have explained why the
plan wouldn't work um and you know again
there's some service the jury would hate
this episode like she would hate
people's like there would be no coming
back like everyone's well there's an
episode where she's like okay she wasn't
that bad or maybe you know she has a
point here is something but it's like no
she said I don't she wouldn't recover
from this one she's not home right now
it's why or I mean you know her liquidy
core don't ya okay okay people are like
well it's a good pitch 50 split some are
like stop it it's no longer funny to
stop yeah I was just like oh wait or
maybe the so yeah and I just I don't
know it's like if the plants won't work
that that's fine the whole idea is
sabotaging them I don't get it see more
like just to throw people for a loop or
to make James look like you didn't know
what he was
really he was okay you know
quote-unquote okay whatever and okay
when you're gonna have a character like
people's do something that is so cruel
you know by having this guy run out and
get killed you know even she is gonna
make another one um but it is just so
cruel and it's such a harsh nd it's a
really harsh way of showing it to have
been Finn's are opening his I see a
little bit and just out the corn foot
according as I sing and get eaten alive
and stuff um and I think you have to be
sure your bases are covered and that
this really is the only way you know
that's why probably the ending of like
x-men - there's a cure it gets killed
off it's like it's the only way I'm like
this 20 other ways out of this got it
Oh killed I don't even remember yeah I
won't give it up but most people the new
x-men movie the x-men to whatever came
out like mm early I think everyone's
seen it so it doesn't matter yes but
okay then I do I have to say who it is I
don't know well you saw it so that's
your own fault um but anyway there's a
million ways out of this scenario where
it's clearly it's like they just wanted
to kill this character off to lead to
something else I that's right with this
felt like they just want to kill this
character off to either get on our
storyline going or make a point that
sometimes you have to make these really
hard choices where people have to die or
whatever and you don't know they're the
right choice I just thought they
could've done a lot better like just a
scenario that really made for a Candy
Kingdom more sense yeah you know IV
within the boundaries and and you know
limitations are lack thereof in this
case of this world
you know a situation that made more
sense cuz I mean you know me I'm all for
going dark I'm fine going really dark
but it has to make sense and it has to
connect together if you're gonna go like
this dark and really kind of mean
because they make the character not very
likable I mean he's not jerk but he's
clearly annoying you know all the
characters are very annoyed by them um I
don't know you really have to be in tune
with this is the only way to do it and
it just seemed like there's a bunch of
other
yeah I don't know um I lean towards not
liking it because I felt they could have
been woven together much better even for
something I don't know I don't even know
if it's like really that necessary to
dabble with I mean maybe it is I don't
know because I guess I've seen stuff
like this like in Batman avatar and
stuff where they a character dies and
they're sort of like no other way around
in the tragedy elements and those
tragedies just happen um but yeah this
one would just seem especially cruel by
having people's be the one that like not
only did she not fin out and he has to
watch a friend of whatever get axed off
but you know she's one of the main
characters you know what a likeable main
characters and like she's really I mean
that is just so harsh and they have such
a harsh thing to do so I don't know I I
think I see what they were trying to do
but I felt it to tackle something like
this you really have to like I said have
all your bases covered I didn't feel
like they did no I agree
like something simple as Oh Jake's like
oh don't worry I'll describe you all
will stretch out of here
and if pb's like you can't do that if
that like acidic crap touches you you
know it will kill you something along
those lines where it's like no you can't
do this because even a droplet of that
touching you will kill you boom that
gets rid of him stretching his
stretching ability I was even saying
like you could stretch himself into the
ship into all the gears that move the
ship I mean it's like cuz they've done
so much of this stuff before you know
even with the Jake suit as soon as you
have the Jake suit and Jake
you know moving Finn around so to me
it's like all bets are off you can do
whatever you want with Jake Jake solves
every problem you know if you can't use
them to me it has to be more of like
like in the episode before he sucks the
blood out and stuff and he's not active
well don't forget about him with the you
know thing in his tooth not to others -
that's right
or like when he has to strike so far
there's only so far he gets stretched
through the maze and so I mean it's like
they're usually very good at that but
you know like I said they didn't even
give it that well I'll have to do a say
if that stuff touches you you could you
could die yeah some way they would do it
yeah um I think the whole reason why
people's was sabotaging everything was
to make them dislike James if they
didn't like James and they didn't trust
James him being killed off wouldn't be
as heartbreaking or hard to deal with
but it still wasn't even then she max
him out I mean it's like why wasn't that
help why wasn't that choice number one
just knock them out and then talk to
James about thank you God there being an
episode it's just you know naturally I
think that's what the whole point was
and she started kind of not it wasn't
working so well so I mean that's my
guess of why she was sabotaging and
making James look bad I could be
completely wrong they can be completely
off base here but it just seems logical
that yeah if you're gonna have to get
rid of someone you might as well start
disliking them so therefore the
disconnect is and let's remember they
just met him for the first time it makes
about as much sense as any of the other
stuff that doesn't make sense I
understand I won't argue that but I will
say this there's I think where they were
trying to go with this episode and I
don't think it's a bad area necessarily
to go is that a lot of times you'll come
across somebody that like you won't get
along whether you'll find them annoying
or whatever and that yeah yeah knocking
off and eventually a lot of times of
these he'll have to sacrifice them to
some strange GUI demons okay okay I want
you to let that go if you bring it up
man but where you'll find something
where it's like it's something either
really valuable really useful or really
incredible about person that
you never thought would come from that
person I I believe every pretty like the
worst person can have something like
wonderful and valuable to offer you know
it's just finding out where to look and
help maybe like in their lifetime they
may we may never see it or they may
never get to it but you know I think
it's it's in there you know but and
that's I think what this episode is
trying to do and I think that's a valid
point but like I said I just didn't
think it was executed that well you just
think people are bred for the slaughter
yes I don't like people
it's very Kubrick I don't like Kubrick
either I think he's a pompous ass who
everyone thinks is so great and his
movies are just I guess his whole thing
was like you know the more yareta Bobby
is just like he really didn't like
humanity like computers should take over
computers are so much better and they
don't get emotional as it just makes
more sense and stuff but it's like but
he is that person ya know it actually
really makes it hip he'll was probably
the hero in 2000 but yeah I I don't know
I think there's possibly a good message
in there trying to get out and it's
trying to be delivered in this very
uncomfortable disturbing way which you
I'm not against it just has to if you're
gonna do that you just have to be ready
and it stuff has to be explained and it
has to be really solid I think there's a
lot of stuff in here that did not come
together in order for that to work well
what I would what I would have liked
better and I mean I agree with you for
the most part on all of it but no
towards the end where Finn is kind of
like waking up from his unconsciousness
and all or being unconscious they should
not have shown him giving her the chunk
of himself right away it should have
been them kind of talking then being
dragged out all of that stuff she
doesn't even say about the cloning it
jumps back to the funeral and they're
dealing with the funeral outcomes
like haha then it cuts back to her
taking the chunk and telling him I can
clone him I can't clone you that bill
would be a little bit yeah that would be
fair because they you wouldn't see it
coming and it would make a funeral even
sadder
exactly and even darker until you see
that but even then it's like wait is
this good as this I don't like them
showing right away him giving that and
then all that it's like Oh duh I know
exactly what's gonna happen I don't
really care now hmm you know James being
annoying or not it was one of those
things it's kinda like ya took away any
impact
I'll be back though I got more important
things to do yo so I guess I'll end this
one real fast um hey